one of the major frustrations throughout
this entire ordeal is the way that
speech was suppressed during the
pandemic I know you experienced it
yourself you were kicked off YouTube for
uh your uh comments about masks and we
now know thanks to the Twitter files the
FBI paid about $3.4 million to Twitter
between October 2019 February 2021 for
its efforts to comply with their
information requests and you recently
asked uh FBI director Christopher Ray
about that director a did the FBA FBI
pay
Twitter money to moderate uh content
moderation I'm not aware of us paying
money to moderate content there or
anywhere else what was the $3 million
for that the FBI gave that's been
revealed in Twitter files then when it
comes to payments uh going back well
over four decades when we are required
by federal law when a company like in
this instance a provider uh goes through
expenses to produce
information uh we're required to
reimburse them for those expenses and so
I think that a lot of the questions
about payments revolve around exactly
that and you will repeat under oath that
there was never any discussion of the
FBI uh to take down constitutionally
protected speech to my
knowledge our agents conducted
themselves in compliance with the law
throughout he said that they simply are
compensating Twitter for taking actions
to address criminal activity um not to
engage in censorship do you believe him
well he may be telling the truth I think
it's an open question but there's the
FBI but there's also the Department of
Homeland Security we do know that they
were working with Stanford University on
internet uh oversight of all kinds of
things not just whether elections are
being influenced by Russians but whether
or not what people are saying about
vaccines we do know from the Twitter
files that they they have acknowledged
and also from the Missouri versus Biden
depositions that they have acknowledged
that even things they felt to be true
but harmful to the government position
deserve to be censored the important
part of this debate though is that we
not get carried away many people on the
right are carried away with how terrible
big Tech is and they now want to
regulate big Tech or Force big Tech to
take their opinions I don't believe in
that at all where I've taken uh um
decided to place my emphasis is on the
government half of this equation if
government is VI meeting with Twitter
and paying Twitter to uh encourage them
to take down constitutionally protected
speech we should limit government from
that interaction government shouldn't be
involved with trying to limit
constitutionally protected speech
however if Twitter wants to censor me or
if YouTube wants to take my speech down
because I say masks don't work that is
their prerogative they're a private
company and I would never want to stop
them but it's important we make this
distinction because there are many on
the right Wing populist part of
particularly the Republican Party who
saying let's just tell Twitter they they
have to take conservative viewpoints or
let's mandate what is actually let's
have a Review Committee I don't want
that at all but I do think that uh a
consistent libertarian position is
telling the FBI Department of Homeland
Security CDC Biden spokesman Biden White
House that they can't be meeting on a
weekly basis with either overt or
implied threats of you need to do this
or else we know the Missouri versus
Biden case that there actually were
threats of antitrust action being
brought against big Tech or getting rid
of their liability protection if they
didn't tow the line that to me is a
clear infringement of the First
Amendment and uh I think is going to
ultimately be uh the decision will
ultimately agree with that will be the
Supreme Court hopefully in the near
future hey thanks for watching that clip
from my conversation with Rand Paul you
can watch another clip right here or the
full conversation over here